I passed on investing in Uber from one
of my best friends twice had I made a
normal 25 000 investment like I was
doing at the time I would have made
somewhere close to 500 million dollars
the reason it doesn't even sit with me
is I also know had I done that my life
would have been completely different
and I don't know that that would have
meant that I would have found myself in
Shanghai one night for a business
meeting that led me to and maybe not
paying attention I would have been hit
by a car and died I believe that you're
scared to like lose that's why you're
not doing anything and that it feels
better to make pretend you're capable
instead of instead of seeing if you're
capable you know what I mean you're
protecting yourself
question I had for yourself uh what are
some of the highly leveraged activities
that you would attribute most of your
success towards gratitude brother my
friend
do you understand that if we went around
this whole Auditorium right now and I
asked people what they're complaining
about that 99 of it is dumb ass [__]
yeah like We complain about the dumbest
[__] and then real [__] happens
and we're like oh [__]
like I have some friends and relatives
that complain so much that it gets me to
such a crazy level I I said to one
relative I'm like and I was like wits
and we were having like a real
conversation I was just like
man I wish something really bad happened
to you
because
I don't mean it but what I was trying to
say to them is like you complain about
nonsense
and Karen at work is ruining me
like you know like just like silly [__]
have you ever like this do you watch
Society I watch somebody berate someone
the other day at the airport for cutting
them in line
great
as if that's some like indeed like
what's the matter I'll tell you what's
the matter people are unhappy
and this game matters we have to fight
for our own happiness over everything
over everything so the high level
activity that happens is I don't
meditate it's not exercise like there's
nothing I don't [__] Watch Rocky 4
videos
I wake up and I say my God another
[__] day on this Earth where the
people I love are good I'm good now let
me go work for 15 hours and have 800
[__] things go wrong
[Applause]
hi Gary diamond from Newcastle it's a
pleasure
who else is from Newcastle
[Music]
[Applause]
Danny do that one more time that movie
was awesome Erica
question on inspiration yes I mean
everybody here has been inspired to be
here yes because of you yes and you
inspired me to write my book as a kid's
book and it's about being inspired to
become who you are amazing
um but we don't often look back so I
often ask kids a lot of the time who are
you inspiring so can you want to talk
about this concept of inspiration
reverse thinking so to speak meaning who
inspired me oh but
um it's it's how we're you're inspiring
us yes well we're not looking behind us
to see who we are inspiring got it the
concept of being accountable to inspire
this is your copy by the way thank you
my friend let me grab it from you I like
so I'm sorry what's the question or are
you looking thank you
is the is the question
you know what do I think about that
concept
no well it's probably more apparent we
know who you your parents inspired you
yes and so let me give you somebody that
really inspires me today yeah that's the
question thank you
I am very inspired by the following
scenario I take a lot of 6 a.m flights
because I'm trying to get home as often
as possible so a lot of times when I
have to fly I'll take the earliest
flight get in do what I have to do and
get home
I am to this day wildly inspired but and
I live in Manhattan in New York City
what that means is we have three major
airports and all of them require me to
go through the city inevitably I'm
leaving at 4 a.m 4 30 in the morning and
I'm watching people get out of the
Subway at four and five in the morning
and there's just something about the
human and and I make up stories for
myself this is not even probably their
real story but I'll watch like a 52 year
old woman come out of the Subway at 4 13
in the morning with three bags and I
think about like is she like the
backbone of her family did she lose her
husband and she has three children and
she's trying to you know provide for I
don't get inspired by like Steve Jobs or
Elon Musk or garyvee I really don't I
genuinely don't I get inspired by the
hundreds of millions of people the
billions of people on Earth that [__]
grind through
to try to make it better for their
family it inspires the living [__] out
of me
like does everybody understand how many
people on earth could not afford to come
to this conference
we are just all uncomfortably blessed
and so I'm inspired by the people in the
dirt that have no choice
and still punch through
because they love the people in their
family
my friend okay Gary my name's uh Clinton
uh firstly from the bottom of my heart
thank you for coming to Australia and
talking to us uh I've been in business
for 25 years I wouldn't actually call it
a business anymore because I was just
struggling day to day through those
businesses
watching your videos certainly has
helped and and being inspired by you is
certainly helped Mike I have a question
that's coming
I Could Just Praise You for half an hour
but I've got a question
where I keep hitting the wall and
struggle all the time and I realize it's
been the problem since I started my
first business is trust trusting in the
team handing that handing the reins over
and it is my problem and I know it's my
problem but I struggle every time
I suppose I'm afraid that I hand it over
and they screw it up I don't have it all
happened this is the problem see I
logically I know that it's the right
thing to do but emotionally have you
practiced I am practicing good and I've
got to say I've had positive out of for
now right but it's still a big struggle
and for me to get to the next level I
have to trust you've got over a thousand
employees brother I understand this so
well because my father trusts no one he
barely trusts me
so what would you say just keep doing it
if it [__] up
well I can tell you this you're not
going to build [__] if you don't trust
it I know that yeah so what do I
recommend
well I screwed up 25 years so make the
next 25 years better do you know what
you just explained is the reason I'm
petrified
of eighth place trophies is when you
tell a child you sucked at this but
we're still going to give you a medal
because we don't want to hurt your
feelings we're telling the child that
losing is bad
you're stuck right now because you think
I know that when I let all my people do
everything that when they [__] it up
that I call the customer and I say I'm
sorry and I fix it
yeah what's gonna happen they're gonna
[__] it up and what
you're going to go out of business no
okay that's what the [__] are we talking
about that's awesome
thank you
[Applause]
so my question is this we hear a lot
about mindset and the importance of
mindset yes what has been the most
recent mindset shift for you and what
treated it
um so I think of mindset and perspective
pretty similarly
the biggest mind shift for me is me not
delivering candor
was protecting people is what I thought
when in reality it was hurting people
and what triggered it was
there's no reason that anyone who's ever
worked for me doesn't love me because I
have incredible intent yet there was
enough people that didn't love me and I
had to be accountable
right so when I would go into former
employee Facebook groups and there was
people [__] on me I couldn't blame
them I had to blame myself and I had to
realize that I had to up my Candor game
and the mind shift the perspective shift
was I wasn't being nice
because then they were just getting
stunned at the end anyway I was actually
hurting them and I needed to have that
mind shift that
lack of Candor is bad not good
and what was that lightning bulk moment
that actually got you thinking other to
do this going to a former Vayner media
employee Facebook group and watching
people that I did incredible things for
over and over saying Gary's a [__]
[__]
they'll do it yeah that'll do it
oh hi Gary my name's Alex hoy
um I have a question um I run the luxury
limousine business I've been like I
apologize real quick yes I just want to
build on that just so everybody hears
this
when people leave negative comments for
me the first thing I do like I said
earlier is I have empathy that they
might be in a bad place
the second thing I do is
spend a lot of time to figure out if
they're right
right I could have easily dismissed
that Facebook group when I have 98 of my
employees Adore Me
you have to have humility to have
happiness
go ahead thank you my name's Alexander I
run a luxury limousine business I've
been lucky enough to have Ethan and
Taryn and Cherie on board with a few
occasions now
um struggling to understand how I would
scale such a critique thing obviously to
fit out of limousines Ultra VIP
concierge service um perhaps some
thoughts on how I could scale charge
more
yeah
all right and um to match the offer of
the gentleman giving a book if you need
the luxury Museum it's a dinner transfer
tonight thank you let's let's play with
this a little bit when you say scale do
you mean more top line revenue
um
I guess replicating but uh obviously
just starting out in the last six months
so I guess cash is oh so you're four
seconds in yeah it's still very very
early it's um it's building networks and
whatnot for the last six months yeah I
mean I mean if you've already got people
like it's it sounds like it's going well
uh let's justify the change of career
leading you know the office World Behind
and uh good for you yeah but um you know
obviously you've got very high Ambitions
and a lot more potential capacities of
course I mean but you're you know think
of a business like a baby
you know your baby is six months old
you're still [__] your pants
[Laughter]
like don't try to run too fast
you know what I mean like
you know asking about scaling six months
into a business is up is premature okay
like it doesn't mean that it's premature
to think about building a big business
but like you're still in fundamentals
mode you're like still just Gathering
your data and you're still just building
the foundation you know don't let your
ambition you know cause you to move too
fast
okay awesome thank you
foreign
I love your ideology around competition
and fighting and having young kids
myself it's challenging raising them in
a different world than the 80s yes so
how do you combat today's challenges and
prepare your kid not only for the future
but their future
by letting them fight
could you come back I guess
the society around that telling them
that the society is wrong okay great
that's what I do so yeah I think I mean
but you know what this is the coolest
thing about parenting you can actually
do that yeah it's so crazy how impactful
parenting is on a human it's like the
one energy you'll listen to that is
encountered to everything going on
outside both pro and con
right I think you know the the current
state of parenting will not eat up your
children it will be an impact but your
voice will be the loudest and so you
just need to stay consistent
cool thank you you're welcome
thank you
hello
yes okay so my name is Phoebe and I am a
midwife so I've been a midwife for about
10 years yes I just decided to put out
myself and build my reputation which was
really good I built up like a really big
Tick Tock and Instagram and everything
and it was so good
and now I realized that I really don't
like being perfect
many clients so many people loving me so
many like have built so much that I'm
like how do I just like leave that and
be like okay I don't want to be a
meatloaf anymore I actually love social
media and I want to teach about social
media so I just feel like I'm at the
point where like I just feel like I want
to cry because everybody like a lot of
women are relying on me to you know be
like [__] the system you know we can do
this but
I don't know how to leave that to go
away so you feel a sense of
responsibility to them yeah but the good
news is you're not the only person that
says [__] the system
you're letting your ego stop you from
your happiness you might feel in Italy
at the moment yes
you believe you're the only person
that's saying [__] the system in
midwifing currently in the world not in
the world not in the world just in Italy
for us
not many but just in Italy my you know
little Community yes um the country of
Italy yeah
tiny Community yeah
you know I think this is a great
question all of us struggle with the
concept of having a sense of
responsibility that's at the Crux and
conflict with our own happiness here's
what I can tell you
if you yourself are not happy you'll
eventually not be able to do the duties
that you're so proud of
so I don't think it's an all or nothing
game you can start interjecting social
media content for every other post that
you do that [__] the system in Italy
around midwifing
yeah you're thinking about it as All or
Nothing
yeah right you're binary yeah yeah I'm
like correct only you know if I do
something I do tend to talk 10 real 10
YouTube ten ten I like I just go all in
yeah I [__] love ten
and so I'm just thinking like how can I
do 20 you know because if I why don't
you
first of all I love that like 20 is
better than 10 but if you can't do that
then what about seven and three
yeah but which one do I choose which one
do you want well I want to do social
media now so these seven social media
and three midwifing okay okay
[Applause]
you want the video this yeah because
this is extra fun done I got you
hey guys
weddings and I write books and I do
podcasts
are supposed to work at so I'm really
looking to tighten this dress away from
Brides in plans weddings and wanting to
help them because it's a really
stressful thing and I really really love
it good but I've just realized from
listening to one of your videos which I
listened to every video a hundred times
when I drive when I work out no matter
what I'm always listening to your stuff
thank you sir and I listened to
something on the way here yesterday
because I live in the hunter Valley yes
and I can't remember who it was because
it was only interested in listening to
you but anyway someone else and they
said what's really your passion and as I
was driving I kind of had what I call a
wow moment yes where I went I absolutely
love weddings Brides drive me absolutely
crazy and I swear like you do but just
not to their faces and I just had a wow
moment that what I really really love is
I love health I love um you know eating
healthy and even if you're busy finding
time to work out and working on your
mental health and I'm that friend that
people they always call me when
something's wrong in their life and I'll
nurture them through it and they're like
what would I have done without you and I
realized that's what I really want to do
but I don't want to leave this so really
sorry it's a really long question is
really short is can I somehow morph the
two businesses together or do I need to
stand them apart you can morph them
together oh yay because it's so much
easier to listen this is what just
happened with the wonderful lady who
loves the number 10 in Italy that's the
only person in Italy
against the system
and a lot of you follow my content I'm
telling you there's something profound
in this if this room collectively falls
in love with the word and
I do not know what it is about you
Beautiful human beings but you have just
decided that or
is more powerful than and
the last two questions and 80 of the
questions and things that I work through
is because people have put the word or
on a pedestal and haven't understood the
word and
it's always and
yeah I guess I just didn't want to
confuse my I've got a really good
following and people kind of trust me
they're going why is she telling me how
to make a bowl of muesliant yeah this is
which is what I do no no so this is
where people don't realize that they're
living their lives for the algorithm and
the likes and the followers and not for
their soul yeah you are not as happy as
you could be because subconsciously what
you actually just said is I don't know
if this content will do as well
I post tons of content that I know will
not do well because I wanted to put out
a nine minute video about sports cards
and 80 of you don't give a [__]
but I don't give a [__] because it makes
me happy
[__] you
hey Gary because of you in the last sort
of six months I've literally dropped 15
kilos and just got in really good shape
and I've got more energy to keep up with
everything and I think that's what I
want to share with people as well
everyone that sees me they go oh my God
you look skinny well but you know what I
mean my weight was evenly proportioned
like you said yours used to be
hold it in a little bit more so thank
you so much
by the way let me go even more technical
because this will free up a lot of you
it used to be a high majority of your
followers would see your [__] if you're
paying attention at home it's not like
that anymore it's the algorithm so now
there's more freedom to post whatever
the [__] you want because
because individual piece of content
that's going to find the audience not
the people that already followed you
got it so this is the greatest era in
social media last 15 years to explore
different creative because it's the
individual piece now it doesn't work
like email anymore where you blast it
and all your people see it the interest
graph not the social graph is what's
dominating the algorithms so now is the
time to take risks and try new [__]
because what they just both talked about
is 90 of what a lot of you are thinking
about if you're producing content
hey Gary my name is Ibrahim so I'm a tax
accountant and in my business I feel
like I give more than what I get paid
for okay
um what do you think is the best way to
close the gap and actually get your true
value of what you're giving to your
clients ask for more
can you expand sure what so you own your
business correct okay so let's say I'm a
client and I last year used you for tax
season yeah
um how much would I pay you roughly I'm
just an individual tax return 164.
yeah dollars okay and what do you think
you're worth my friend my friend um
individuals aren't really my priority
I'm talking businesses so for example
bookkeeping payroll the whole yeah let's
say I was using you for that how much am
I paying you uh generally between two to
three thousand dollars depending on the
amount of transactions depend on payroll
and what kind of contract do you and I
currently have if I'm one of these
customers
um a one-year deal a month-to-month deal
no contract how do we do it month to
month great send me an email tomorrow
and say dear Gary I'm giving you 90 days
notice my services are now four thousand
dollars a month
okay and what happens if let's say 90 of
them leave well then you were wrong
[Applause]
the market the market doesn't give a
[__] about your feelings of what you're
worth yep
you're in business
okay here's the good news I wouldn't
take the risk of emailing all of them
back
how many businesses do you have like
that uh at the moment I've just got them
up to about 10 I'm closing in one two
tomorrow
so you've got 10 people that do
month-to-month like that so I would take
two or three of them probably the oldest
ones you've had and I would send that
email and see what happens
okay are you scared if they're gonna go
away not really I couldn't care less
I just want more money great
you are about to find out what your
Market is you may end up with far less
money
but that's the plan brother you've got
ten take your two longest clients say
Hey you may want to do a phone call
because instead of hey do you have 10
minutes to talk you get them on the
phone that's a respectful way and say
hey I've got a lot of Demand on my time
my business is going in a different
direction how long have you had your two
longest clients
uh about two and a half years perfect I
think you call them and say hey maybe
get together in person I don't know if
you're local or you get them on the
phone that's the right thing to do not a
cold email and say Hey you know we've
been together for two and a half years I
really respect your business I just want
to give you an update
um starting January 1st we're already in
August this is perfect starting in 2024
my services are going to 4 000. I have
too much demand you know we move to the
next level
um but I want to give you plenty of time
because I'd love to keep you because I
think it's really worth it but just in
case you need to move I want to give you
some time to start looking and you're
about to learn what your Market is worth
thank you you're welcome
hey what's up Gary I'm Jane um first and
foremost I just want to say thank you so
much you spoke in Brisbane in 2018 uh I
was in 200 000 debt I had a full-time
job and your talk inspired me to start a
business that day I use my grocery money
to start my agency and six weeks later I
quit my job and a year and a half later
I paid off my 200 000 debt thank you
so my question is uh what's your
thoughts on what's happening with Elon
musk's Rebrand with Twitter turning into
X it seems like there's quite a debate
happening what's happening with threads
and what can content creators expect and
how can we capitalize on this threads is
early but it's really a lot of Twitter
Dynamics but different audience because
most people you know were so Instagram
heavy that's where our community was
it's a real opportunity obviously
there's not as much the first week is
always like a grand opening of a
restaurant there's always going to do
different you know it takes time that
we'll be watching what's happening with
threads on the X part you know names are
interesting he obviously gave up a lot
of brand value because there's a lot of
brand built in Twitter at the same token
it's very clear he's trying to build an
app that looks more like what we see in
China where it's full service and a lot
of ways for him to get permission to
build out an app that has 7 10 15
different services on it one could argue
the rebranding of it actually gives him
the ability to make us believe that X
fits all these things whereas Twitter we
knew what it was and it was harder to
Rebrand so at the end of the day with
the way I think about memes is names are
made people like Gary I need a great
name for my business otherwise it won't
do well I'm like Google's a terrible
name
Nike's a shitty name McDonald's sounds
like a local Irish Pub me
games are made by execution so then the
name debate is kind of not super
interesting it's gonna end up completely
being judged on his ability to execute
the thing
do you think that um he's potentially
disrupted the community Beyond a measure
that he can repair it or do you think
that he could potentially rebuild it
into something new yeah I mean I think
the data shows that
more hyperbole than truth
thank you yeah I try not to like get
caught up in like hot takes I like to
look at reality
the community is either making a
subjective political decision on their
belief systems but in reality
most people are keyboard Warriors and
talk [__] but act differently
right like in America every four years
fifty percent of the country tells me
that they're going to leave America if
this person wins the election if blah
blah blah wins the election I'm moving
to Canada and then like next Thursday I
see him like Hey Bob
nobody's moving to [__] Canada bro
yeah
thank you so that's what's going on with
that
hey Gary I'm Simone nice to meet you
you've inspired me to start my business
three years ago and we're now turning
over about three million in Revenue each
year
foreign
people having conversations with me now
around what my end goal is and I'm just
wondering how you would find out when
it's time to sell or step out so that I
can focus on other business ventures do
you like it
I enjoy the business side of it not the
operations
do you want to bring in an operator
and what do you consider the business
part if it's not the operations
strategy interesting and you so
do you have an idea for another business
that you believe that you'll like better
because it's more strategy because every
business needs operations
I love what we do I'm very passionate
about it still so I haven't lost the
passion but I've got other ideas that I
think could be bigger I manage 50 staff
right now so that's quite draining um
why don't you hire someone sorry I've
got a team of four admin so across us we
kind of do that any escalations come to
myself what about bringing in somebody
more senior to be like a gender
operations director
I do have one how about another one
the profit's nice
um so I mean that's an idea but how
would you position the two would you
have enough make less confident be
happier but what would the two roles be
to buy and Conquer responsibilities it's
operations it's not hard or would you
have a COO yes
you know what I mean like you could go
that way you could easily have two
people that report to you and they
divide but like I love that we got to
that place you're literally compromising
your ability to start something else
be happier all for a couple shekels on
the profit margin the other thing
tonight is I could probably double the
income in about one or two years as well
if I really hustled in what we're
currently doing the real thing you
should know is if you hire a capable
people to do [__] that you don't love
you might be able to triple it
yes
I didn't get up here with my looks
thank you
that was some gangster [__] right yeah
yeah
hi Gary my name is Roy Roy how are you
very well that's good excellent uh you
spoke about loving your life love yes
loving your life yes and you um
you spoke about a whole lot of people
that don't love their life yes when did
you start loving your life and when did
you consider yourself to be successful
because I mean if you if you if you
compare yourself to where you started
off would you consider yourself
successful or at what point Did you sort
of turn around and say you know what I'm
a success
I I
Started Loving my
muscle
[Music]
um so I would say yeah I'm being serious
like school was a burden on me and I
hated it and it took up a lot of time so
I would say the day I fully went there
was like I've always loved like I would
say around 10 or 11 is when I started to
understand myself in a funny way where I
was willing to be bad at school and did
not think it represented who I was so
that was like an early seed when I
really had nothing on my chest other
than Joy was when I was done with school
because that was a burden
I I've never really deemed myself
successful or not successful I've never
judged myself
so when when do when would you say that
you started really loving your life sort
of because there was a moment where
you'd say you know you were the 20 um
the 28 year old wine cellar working for
your father
were you loving life at that point yes
fair enough
I just my bigger question to you is
what's making you not love your life
that's a great question so answer it
not achieving not achieving what I think
that I can achieve for whom for me what
are you why are you doing that to
yourself
I don't know it's it's a matter of not
achieving I think that I'm capable of
more than one thing so it's a matter of
do I go in this direction do I go in
that direction where do I commit where
do I put the effort where do I put but
what are you scared of that's not
letting you make decisions missing out
on the other things that that you know
if I go down One Direction you miss out
on another thing can I give you some
really really good news yeah
no matter what you ever decide you'll
never know if the other thing would have
been anything
so dive in commit you're not gonna
sitting around and debating which
options better will never show you which
option is better let me give you an
example
I passed on investing in Uber from one
of my best friends twice had I made a
normal 25 000 investment like I was
doing at the time I would have made
somewhere close to 500 million dollars
the reason it doesn't even sit with me
is I also know had I've done that my
life would have been completely
different
and I don't know that that would have
meant that I would have found myself in
Shanghai one night for a business
meeting that that would have led me to
and maybe not paying attention I would
have been hit by a car and died
I believe that you're scared to like
lose
that's why you're not doing anything
and that it feels better to make pretend
you're capable instead of seeing if
you're capable
you know what I mean you're protecting
yourself
so let's bubble wrap most School fights
is everything that's right but you know
what I mean like like it's so fun to be
like
like I'm
um what's burning you up inside is you
know the truth you know the coolest
thing about being a person is you
actually know
what thank you for I mean I thought it
was the most profound thing I said all
day so I I think you're [__] amazing
for that class
and I'll tell you where me and you are
sharing this moment
people are posturing
the reason you're hurting inside is you
know you're acting
but inside you know you're scared of
[__] you're scared that's why you're not
doing it you're not scared of missing
out on the alternative you're scared of
doing
because if you do then you might fail
you got to practice losing my man
instead of making pretend you won't lose
thank you you're welcome thank you
you're welcome
because brother because I see that hit
for you don't worry about their judgment
like what's going to happen you're going
to fail and then your mom or your dad or
your best friend is going to see see you
suck and you're going to say what you
suck too
[Laughter]
doing it is this fake game that
everyone's playing so someone can tell
them like if you don't play you didn't
lose
the biggest thing I fear when I see in
children is Their Fear to play the game
because it means they're scared of
losing
that means they're insecure
hi guys I'm Kira and I've recently set
up a business and set up an Instagram
account for us and I've just started
taking videos and talking to the camera
and I can't get over my fear of just
feeling like everything sounds really
cringy and like worrying about what
other people think like how would you
kind of get past that at the very
beginning of the journey
by posting okay you know like like yeah
this is all the same game this is why
this is so interesting to me dear like
like again play this game with me that
we just played what's gonna happen like
Ricky pants 49's gonna say you're cringy
what's gonna happen your high school
friends are gonna be like you're so
cringy like the concept of valuing other
people's opinions over your own is crazy
yeah it's understandable but it's just a
game of insecurity this that thing that
I said 20 minutes ago if everyone just
stays in high school you're in high
school right now I tell people all the
time when you were in high school and
you were scared to go to school because
you had a huge zit the reason it was
fine was everybody who else was scared
about their own zit
like people need to get over themselves
like nobody really gives a [__] about
your cringy video
okay like the reason like the reason
I think is easy for me is even with all
this love and admiration
like what's gonna happen I'm gonna die
if you're around and you like me you're
gonna be like send whatever the text or
tweet or Facebook of the day you're
gonna be like Gary he was awesome he
really maybe you'll share the stories
that you're sharing with me and then
you're gonna hit enter and then you live
your [__] life
right
right so what the [__] are you scared of
I don't know like I'm still posting
every day and putting it off and I've
even spoken on my stories about signing
cringey but like it's my own fear and
like people have messaged me saying no
you're not going to keep going but I
think it's just like this fear that I'll
give myself the ick really bad and then
just not post
[Music]
you're in
telling you you're not cringy so you
just keep
no I think some I think it's more from
myself why
I think because it's so new I've never
really spoken to the camera before so
it's like foreign to me what if it's
awesome okay
what if this is what you were meant to
do I mean again like these Mind Games we
play with each other are just totally
irrelevant yeah
okay just keep doing it okay you'll get
more used to it it's kind of like why
didn't I give Canada because I didn't
want to hurt their feelings it made me
feel bad but then the more practice you
get better yeah okay thank you you're
welcome
[Applause]
got a lot of um clients that I would
really love working working for and um
and I understand the lifetime value for
the client yes
how would you reward those kind of
clients that you really love to work for
by reverse engineering what makes them
happy
so I said basically asking them what
makes them happy and and then do it do
it
like
if they're interested in the football
team for instance
buying them a jersey or yeah something
like that that's right
thanks you're welcome
but it but it's interesting right like
that's by the way I love that you're
into like like my favorite book that I
wrote is the thank you economy that only
speaks about this
the fact that you have the intent for
this brother you're halfway home now you
just got to spend time with them take
them out to dinner you don't even need
to ask them so transactionally take them
out to dinner and talk about life and
then realize that they like that sports
team then you're gonna get double the
love from them because you were
listening to them instead of asking them
you know spend time
every great relationship you have is
based on the amount of time you spent on
it
hi Gary hi my name is Gabby
um I'm 27 years old which means that I'm
constantly having to re-watch the
patience video and remind myself about
it
um but you also do mention also the
importance of being able to make
decisions quickly so I was wondering
what your advice would be how how I can
balance being patient with something but
also being able to make a decision
because I think if it is macro patients
micro speed
in the macro when I'm asking you to be
patient I'm asking you to not judge
judges in the micro when I'm asking you
to make a decision I'm hoping that you
realize you need to make a decision or
nothing's going to happen so give me a
for instance of something that you
struggle to make a decision on
um so say for example in I have an
e-commerce store that sells a particular
product so I know that it's a good
product but
do I double down on that product do I
give it a bit more of a chance to scale
dramatically or is it time to Pivot why
do you know it's a good product
from the reviews I've gotten from
customers from the fact that there
wasn't anything like it in the market
and from customers from overseas finding
it somehow so why are you contemplating
moving on because there's not enough
volume yeah well maybe you're not good
at marketing
ironic because I'm a digital marketing
manager
yeah ironically that's the least ironic
thing to me most people that I see in
marketing roles aren't actually great at
marketing
are you a digital marketing manager in
like a career and this is a side product
yeah I think what I've struggled with is
because I've gone through a career in
corporate yeah being able to somehow
transmute that to a small business is
completely different there's you have
just loud articulated why I'm dominating
in corporate
corporate marketing is fake yeah
business marketing for yourself is real
so it would be kind of unlearning
yeah
funny thing happens when you have
clients and you're telling them what to
do for marketing but if that's it matter
because it's not yours but then all of a
sudden when you got yours yeah I think
you need to get better at marketing yeah
I think so too I think that's a reality
check I needed good I'm happy to do it
you got it
all right three more questions
can we extend it a little bit yeah
[Applause]
hi Gary my name's Nick
um my question is about you know your
why your purpose yes and for me
um it's my kids yes um I grew up not
very well off and I started my own
business so that I've got the time
freedom to be able to drop them off at
school because from school it's awesome
um and basically provide the kind of
life that I never had amazing
problem where I'm starting to feel torn
is I have such a time commitment in what
I'm doing that I feel like it's taken me
away from the kids who are the driving
horse of everything I do so don't
yeah
um I just I feel like I don't have
enough time to fulfill both and but you
do
what you're doing is you're judging
yourself on ideology
and you're trying to be perfect
and you think it's a game of or not and
and you're saying that because I didn't
drop off my kids today on this Tuesday
because I went to this business thing I
[__] up when in reality your kids have
no prayer of remembering that [__] in 15
years
[Music]
it's true
all right cool
brother this is the black and white [__]
that we gotta get out of
the fact that you're even trying your
kids are going to feel that
who the [__] is perfect
not mine nobody
of course you're not perfect nobody is
but you're trying
[Music]
and you clearly have the intent sounds
like your kids are super lucky
and so if you've got to go hard for a
month because there's an opportunity in
what you're doing and you might miss the
ball game or dropping them off it's just
a tiny blimp how old are your kids
uh nine and six I want you to tell all
of us right now every day of your nine
and six year old life go
sh can't do that tell me 25 things that
happened to you when you were nine
couldn't do that either
then I think you should go do both
thanks Gary you understand let's
you remember what you feel not every
detail
we're beat this is what I'm talking
about I'm so happy he came up and
brother that was such a good one do you
know how many people you just helped
like right how many people did that just
help
[Applause]
this concept like I don't know what
people are doing
you have to be perfect for your kids
every day you have to love your kids
you don't have to go to every [__]
game
most of your kids suck at the game
anyway
like literally like we created this
[__] pressure on ourselves nobody can
do everything
you have to provide for your family and
your employees and go to everybody [__]
like you know like Little Ricky's gonna
be okay if you miss one [__] game
and if you don't want to then don't then
your business will make a little less
money that's good but it's not about the
money is it it you need it for yourself
this is what I keep telling people if
you're a provider financially or
emotionally you have to protect yourself
first because if you're doing for
everyone else and not yourself you're
going to eventually break and the whole
thing is going to fall apart
the only way to be selfless is to start
by being selfish
thank you so I came here today with my
co-founder who's at the back and we met
three years ago at a support group after
our mum's day suddenly we struggle to
find resources that spoke to us you know
people our age we didn't expect to go
through such a big loss and so we had a
chat about what can we do to help other
people and so we started a podcast and
it was really successful with in the
last three years we've written a book
we've got a highly engaged Community but
we're struggling to sustain ourselves
financially and it's such a sensitive
topic we don't know how to monetize it
um so I'm just looking for some advice
maybe you shouldn't
right maybe it can be a side thing that
fills your soul and maybe you guys can
do something else that feels more pure
to monetize
we do feel like it like we've found our
purpose and the thought of like going
back to the jobs that we were doing
before kind of like make us feel a bit
physically sick that makes sense
what about not going back to those jobs
and doing something else that's either
financially viable together or jobs that
might be enjoyable that may not pay as
much but give you the time to work on
this and maybe an in between because if
you can't like if you don't if you can't
monetize on the subject matter you can't
monetize
right yeah or you find a way that feels
right
right whether it's selling Retreats or
something there might be a way to do it
yeah but do not
the number one thing that I always worry
about is people compromise
what they feel in their stomach because
of the financial burden I'd rather you
keep this pure
and work around it then ruin it
good advice thank you welcome
[Applause]
I'm a project manager at the best
advertising agency in Australia
over the years I've realized my goals
aren't to climb the corporate ladder or
chase the title but I still care about
my career and I love to learn develop
and grow my question is how can I make
sure I feel fulfilled and that I'm
growing without having to chase the
title
I mean it doesn't sound like you're
putting the title on a pedestal
doesn't that just end the game right
there
all right
I promise you that we'll never promote
you and give you a better title
No but really do you know what do you
feel like there's a part of you that
feels like you're supposed to I think
that's just the way that the corporate I
actually think you and I might be very
similar let me explain
when I hear them I think that so I am
who I am but I give it no power
you could be the chief production
officer of vaynermedia one day globally
but if you don't think that validates
you then it holds no power
like I I don't think I don't give any
power to me being garyvee or being the
CEO of Vayner
so you can still grow
but that doesn't mean you sold out or
you compromised if you don't give it any
weight
I I believe that I want to be judged on
how I treat people not by how much money
I make
so you can you can continue to crush at
Vayner like you're doing and keep
getting promoted but if you are detached
from that title then you are detached
from that title
you understand
keep up the good work
I am I'm Pauline Ethan thank you so much
for showing us what introverts can do
and Gary the most freeing thing you ever
said is you are the niche you don't have
to box yourself in
having said that um I was wondering if
you you spoke about self-love and I
didn't realize business things talked
about that it's really like I like how
squishy it's getting right now yeah I
can get way more squishy than this so
like do you especially because I deal
with a lot of traumatized people and
they come to me and they they've never
told people their staff especially men
as well yes do you have like a daily
self-love ritual or something that you
practice to either stay happy or
maintain that that self-worth
yeah but it's not even like daily it's
almost minute by minute
I just am incapable of losing the
perspective of the truth
you know like I it's you know it's
really interesting to watch the world
get more spiritual right there's so much
on that now
and I love it I love that people have
found different ways whether they're
doing meditation whether they're walking
on grass to get grounded whether they're
[__] doing psychedelic I don't give a
[__] whatever makes people happy I'm
about
it's just fascinating for me because it
all just makes me happier and happier by
the nanosecond because it just is for me
you know it's just it's
surreal when I said to you I can get way
more squishy my most Inner Circle my
friends and family laugh about the whole
garyvee thing so much because I'm such
an aggressive Communicator in my content
because I get hyped and I get excited
and unlike some people when the camera
comes on they feel weird the camera
comes on me and I think I'm Randy the
Macho Man Savage you know like I go
crazy but [__] man am I super chill
and what the what the [__] is there to
stress about
you're going to be dead for a long time
thank you you're welcome
so back to the point of like me saying I
could be way more squishy and back to
the point of not being attached to it
like I'm on some nothing matters [__]
and I don't think anything matters
nothing
zero
just like
[__] be happy today
you know they fight for that [__] at all
costs
so that's why I can get very squishy
because I can go very deep on this
I like my craft i'm passionate I do my
thing but like what the [__] does it
mean
who here spends time with 90 year olds
that are not their relatives
then I guarantee those six or seven
hands you should if you're paying
attention know what to do which means no
90 year old is talking about any of the
nonsense that's running through your
head
hi Gary how are you a moment thank you
my name my name's Nathan um so I I just
wanted to say that I really appreciate
like all the content that you've been
putting on social media like you're one
of the main reasons why I started to put
more effort into my social media and
start posting a lot more I mean
particularly on LinkedIn I've noticed
that I'm getting a lot more traction
obviously I don't have a hundred
thousand followers or anything but I'm
seeing that one percent better every day
and I think I like to have you to think
in a large part for that so I'm very
grateful
um yeah so my question
um actually it's more of a the audience
of dial it back a little bit so I'm
building a business of my own and I'm
currently in the stage of like doing
market research and I'm validating some
stuff that I'm working on like do people
really like what I'm selling and do
people really want I wanted to ask you
like in your experience with all of the
businesses you've done you've been able
to achieve amazing things but I wanted
to ask you like what are some examples
of things that you've done that haven't
worked well and maybe what would you do
differently
super fascinating
my ability to
even remember [__] that didn't work is
an extreme Challenge for me
so what hasn't worked
many different initiatives within Vayner
right
um I've been trying to start a Boehner
Live Events to the company and division
multiple times I try to sampling
division inside of Vayner
it's like almost everything doesn't work
like
you know
I'm also good at it so a lot of things
do work but
you know I I never bet the whole Farm on
things notice how I helped a guy with
the tax thing like you don't email all
10 because the [__] might [__] up you go
to two and if it [__] up you're still
alive so I have this year of high risk
I've never put myself out of business
and I'd really not done that many things
in the scheme of things meaning I've
done a ton of things but like betting
all of it but even like think about the
clarity that I've given almost every
answer on this and this gentleman's
asking me like what things haven't
worked I'm like trying to process here
on stage but hasn't worked it's like I'm
not sure
it doesn't matter
like and nothing ever really big you
know like I've never been the active
Runner of a business that didn't succeed
there's been side projects
uh one at one point I tried to start a
full pledge buying toys at garage sales
and selling them on eBay business and I
put like
friend in a cousin
because but like I didn't run it
do you know what I mean it was like I
set it up and so usually if I'm driving
it's gonna be okay but many initiatives
haven't worked
so it's just more of a case of like
you've always said many times it's just
executing trying things seeing what was
like executing on a small screen yeah
the biggest the biggest thing I fear
about when I hear you frame this up is
how long are you gonna do
oh I'm I'm I want to get started as soon
as possible like I've just I've gathered
a bunch of data already I'm now on the
Press because of actually executing
something I'm thinking to myself now I
just need to start just get out there
and just do it that's what I think about
it that's right okay thank you very much
yeah I really apologize we're gonna have
to cut it at this one go ahead brother
and for for you who's like devastated
yeah I saw the reaction we're gonna
sneak it in too because that was a big
reaction okay go fast
hi Gary my name is ashik I'm a
structural engineer thank you for being
the one who pushed me to double down on
my passion and finally create a brand
that educates the general public on
structural engineering and the important
work that Structural Engineers do in the
world those Structural Engineers
you [__] [__] this shit's
important
don't forget to thank yourself my
question to you is in the last year I've
come to realize that the majority of my
family and friends don't share the same
growth mindset as me while I don't let
this hold me back from doing the work I
can't help but sometimes have this
unhelpful thought that if I really went
all in and achieved my true potential
I'd be leaving my loved ones behind how
do I overcome this mindset that's
holding me back by realizing that's the
dumbest [__] I've ever heard in my life
why would you succeeding leave why
wouldn't you bring them with you
that is 100 what I want to do but it's
just this thought that just keeps
holding me back and I'm not sure why it
happens I don't know if I'm the only one
that that has this let's keep playing
with this is fascinating and I think
it's something else actually so let's
keep playing you succeed and what
happens you become so bougie you don't
want to talk to them anymore no it's not
really that it's they become jealous of
you
yesterday first of all can text you this
is family and friends and it might be
more about friends as well so I love my
friends and I know they look out for me
but it's just this thought that yeah
maybe if I do really achieve my true
potential I could make them feel
uncomfortable and that could result in a
growing gap between us I don't know it's
just it's a great thought I mean I grew
up in such a scenario where that became
very real in my world but let's keep
playing would you start trying to bring
them along absolutely not I've actually
done this end of story
if they're deeply insecure and they
start to be jealous of you if you
counter their Darkness with more light
you'll win
thank you you understand yeah nobody
leaves anyone behind if they choose to
not leave them behind
what about the duality of responsibility
100 that's exactly right it's equally
that person's responsibility to work on
themselves but one of the easiest ways
to help people work on themselves is to
continue to shower them with support and
love
of course
limiting your entrepreneurial ability
because you're providing so much energy
to someone that you're trying to bring
along is highly unlikely actually
there's so much energy of course it
would take some
but yeah you could limit your upside I
did it I built Wine Library while being
my dad's personal therapist three hours
a day in that liquor store
I pack of peanuts it wasn't the end of
the [__] world
so to your point but in reality it's all
just subjective at that level right like
sure I gave up three hours a day and
that would have been productive when I
put into the entrepreneurial Journey but
I loved him more and I needed to bring
him along
foreign
[Applause]
he might also be able to go out and do
it for three years and then come back
the game's not over until everyone's
dead
right
the more important question is to your
point his point is like okay then don't
like that's what gets fun about these
philosophy and these debates okay if if
you don't want to do what many many many
many many many of hundreds of millions
of people have done by bringing people
along you're allowed to choose to not to
that's exactly right like you know but
I'm on the receiving end of a question
to create you know a framework but then
you get to decide
I can tell you this
if you decide to compromise your
happiness and upside because you're
scared to leave people behind because
you don't want to make them feel bad I
have some bad news you're going to
really make them feel bad in 20 30 years
when you start deploying your resentment
on them
thank you Gary
all right brother last question
lucky last beautiful uh well it's an
honor thank you very much for giving me
the opportunity to um have a chat and I
just want to skip all the intro stuff
nobody cares who the [__] I am I'm in
here for a little bit
uh you spoke before about a quote
somebody else created this framework for
judging yourself
could you elaborate on that a little bit
more yeah because I believe that I
created this framework for judging
myself I believe that as a recovering
perfectionist that I am my biggest
critic and I believe if I showed you the
video of the first five years of your
life and every single thing your parents
grandparents and people around you did
it all clear for you that you had
nothing to do with that
um
you know we can remember at a certain
level
the problem is a lot of things are being
formed before we can remember
so it's just just very obvious by the
way you have children enough
okay do you plan on it yes okay
this is going to get very clear for you
when
you know like we're animals
and we're being nurtured by our
environment this [__] was figured out
long before I came look I promise you
that the nature nurture thing is real
and so there's something incredibly
liberating
for a lot of people once they realize
it's not you hating you because that's
very complicated and painful
if I'm honest I'm still not 100 gay I
understand what you're saying about the
environment Etc but could you elaborate
that a little bit more yeah well like it
just depends on how you want to play the
game so for example
we all have our DNA yeah um do you think
you're responsible for your really good
looking face
I wish I was because I'm damn good
looking I agree
[Applause]
so you don't think you're responsible
for your face but you do think you're
responsible for your insecurity
hmm
yeah I get the inconsistency there yeah
yeah well so when you said um when you
love yourself it's all gravy yes what
does that feel like the [__]
like it really feels great to feel light
it feels nice and of course I'm a human
being it's not like I'm [__] in la la
land but when the foundation is good
when you really do fight like for me
when I'm struggling with something and
I'm stressed it fascinates me how much
my natural like framework starts to
fight me out a bit like how quickly
whether it's an hour or a half a day
like everything is forcing myself into
like okay hold on so you're stressed
about this
but let's we pretend this was fine
and X happened someone that you care
about was sick or that like very quickly
I go to the higher level of perspective
and so that practice so like it's just
it feels nice to not worry all the time
you know about things that are silly
it's good to worry about the important
things you know you need the health and
well-being of yourself and your loved
ones after that it's like
everything else is manageable
and before you ask uh you were saying
about how the environment shapes you Etc
I'm not going to remember it's a piece
Etc now
I remember before you also said not to
be angry at your mom and your dad Etc
because their grandparents made them
yeah [__] your grandparents yeah so I
actually feel like my dad is one of my
biggest sources of fuel like when I
reach into the cookie jar
I written to my dad it's not essential
right
and I feel like a lot of the reason why
I've been able to achieved the amount of
success that I have is because of his
lack of belief his negativity Etc I
don't feel like I'm sorry
yeah that's right that's what it is
that's the thing I'm scared of are you
mad at him I'm not sure should I be mad
that's really the essence of my question
because if you're not sure what the [__]
do you want from me
what do you think uh do you think you're
mad at him or do you think you feel bad
from him for him and it's allowing you
to try in a different way
you might have compassion for him
Oh by and large I'm happy because as I
said that's the large fuel for what's
flowing me forward I think my biggest
purpose in life is really not I want to
be like see I did it right that's called
being Darth [__] Vader
that's the dark energy hard to be
sustainable yeah when does that end of
you proving him wrong
is that a million dollars is that a is
that a million followers is that having
a hot plus one like where does that stop
I've got a pretty clear destination
actually when we're doing eight figures
why not nine
well I think that'll be enough for me
yeah
why not seven sorry then why not seven
well because I'm already there okay so
what like but why eight and that nine
you do what you think that
um once we're like figures then I'll be
able to say hey Dad look we've
influenced this many people we've saved
this many lives he's gonna say I don't
give a [__]
what I'm trying to play out with you is
you just arbitrarily made that up
yeah cool I get it now all right awesome
thank you guys thank you so much for
being here ladies and gentlemen thank
you city thank you so much
thank you so much
[Music]